-This feels great.
Doesn't it feel great?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love this guy so much.
Joining me right now is a
16-time WWE world champion,
a talented actor,
and a "New York Times"
best-selling author,
who has a brand-new
children's book out today called
"Elbow Grease: Fast Friends."
Please welcome our pal,
the one, the only John Cena.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I love your elbows ♪
♪ I love your elbows ♪
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Thank you, guys.
-That is John Cena, our first
in-studio guest, right there.
Yeah, as far back as
you want, yeah.
-No, this is 6 feet.
I was just doing the --
-Oh, the perfect --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You look fantastic.
-I mean, this is the first time
I have seen you
in like eight months, man.
-It really is, yeah.
-It's very special.
-You got all dressed up.
-And you didn't.
[ Laughter ]
You repeatedly like, "I really
value our friendship,"
and repeatedly on this show,
you hurt my feelings.
-Yeah, I know, I do.
Yeah, but, no, the thing is,
most of my guests
for the past six months have
been in pajamas, so this is --
-These are my pajamas.
-Oh, wow!
You really sleep in
some fancy stuff, man.
Congrats on everything
that's going with you.
I can't even tell you
what it means to us, to me
that you would come on the show.
We've known each other
for a long time.
We've done a lot of
crazy things, a lot of firsts.
-We have.
And here's the problem
for everybody watching at home.
This is just going to end up in,
like, a bro hang.
You know, we're supposed to
do the interview.
and, like, talk about
the book and stuff,
but it's just gonna be a bro --
I miss you, man.
I love you. I miss you.
You're the best.
It's an absolute honor
to be here with you,
with you guys,
with the 12 in the audience,
the most energetic
"Tonight Show" audience
I've ever seen.
-Six to 12.
I'd say probably seven.
-Estimated 7. Yeah.
Seven sounding like 12.
-It just means a lot.
For everyone even
watching at home,
you know, you're making
a lot of people happy right now.
So thank you so much
for doing it.
-And, man, I appreciate
you having me here.
but also doing it the right way.
I mean, tested when we got in.
Everybody is social-distancing,
covered in protective gear.
I've never felt more safe.
And even -- Man, as much as I
want to give you a big old hug,
we're 6 feet and we're doing it
the right way.
So it's a start.
-Yeah, I agree. Thanks.
The last time we hung, really,
like, and bro'ed out --
-We crushed beers.
-Yeah, we crushed beers.
-We crushed beers together.
We were in a Michelob ULTRA ad.
-Like I said, it's just
gonna be a bro hang.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. You guys were there.
-That's right.
-Brooks Koepka was there.
-Yeah, it was insane.
-What a weird dream.
-It was bizarre.
-Yeah.
-Well, I had
so much fun with you, though.
I got to spend
three days with you.
And let me tell you
what it's like to spend
three days with John Cena,
because it is just mayhem
once we leave the hotel room.
It is -- Everyone recognize --
They don't care about me at all.
They just, like, push me
out of the way, like,
"John Cena, John Cena,
John Cena!"
But then you're
so nice to everybody.
I will never forget this.
A kid came up to you --
A little boy came up to you,
and he just flipped out,
like, couldn't control
his emotions and started, like,
shaking and crying.
And you were so cool to him
and nice to him.
It's, like, this --
It was just amazing to see,
and then he was like,
"Hi, grandpa."
He pointed at me, and I go,
"Yeah, I'm not that old.
I'm not that old. Please."
Yeah.
>> Well, to be honest, dude,
I'm that kid to you,
because you don't know,
like, that commercial
meant a lot to me, because that
commercial was for you.
And Michelob came to ask you
to be like,
"Yeah, we need kind of like
a mentor, coach,
get-you-in-shape,
toughen-you-up type of guy,"
and you're like, "Yo, I want to
hang with John Cena."
And we crushed beers and made
a Super Bowl commercial.
Like, what a crazy life.
-We got to hang. We got to joke.
We got to sing.
Thank you for singing
"Reunited" with me.
Thank you, Roots,
for playing that.
-Just add that to the list of
crazy [bleep] we've done.
-But, I mean,
what is your go-to music?
Is that --
-You know, if I'm going to sing,
it's probably, like --
I've probably had one too many
and I'm probably singing,
like, sad country.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Oh, I love good sad country.
I think it's 'cause, like --
Like, "Friends in Low Places"
or anything by Johnny Cash
or Merle or Waylon or Willie.
-Willie. Oh, The Outlaws.
-Hank Sr. Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-'Cause that's like
you don't really --
I don't have much skill, so...
-Oh, please. Yeah.
-That's kind of where I live.
-We have -- For me,
it's BTS Week,
so I have nothing but BTS love.
That's all we do here.
That's all we do.
-I jam out to them.
-How about this?
So, when we were with BTS last
time, we were talking,
and I was like, "Who --
Is there anyone --
Just name someone
you would like to meet,"
and they all said, "John Cena."
-Floored me.
-I know you saw that.
-Like, stopped my heart.
-It was so cool.
But then the BTS Army
kind of embraced you
and, like,
"Please be part of our --
-Well, see, that's what's --
When something becomes a thing,
it's open for criticism.
And I love what
this band has done,
because they are this
massively popular thing
and they have been so
globally popular for so long.
Then I was like, "Okay, I should
probably know about this."
And when I started to
look at BTS
and listen to their music,
I was originally drawn
because, like,
there are rappers in that crew,
and they use --
On some of their intro tracks
and, like, bookend tracks,
they use, like,
sick-ass boom-bap beats
and they actually rap.
So, like, yeah,
I kind of like this.
This is great.
-Yeah.
So, I got interested in
the music
and then I got interested in
what the music stood for.
And they advocate self-love.
They advocate
don't be afraid of failure.
They advocate that
you are enough.
They kind of are trying to
shatter all the
stereotypical difficulties
and uncomfortable situations
that we go through and they are
catering to an audience
that is living that --
young people.
So, like, that's why they are so
popular around the world.
One, they're great performers,
but it's the message
they send --
it resonates with the people.
And, on top of that, they've
developed this a global army,
this BTS Army, that is not
just, like, geeked-out fans.
Like, BTS donated a
million bucks to
Black Lives Matter,
and the army was like,
"Yo, if they can do it,
we can do it."
And they came --
Like, fans, who are already
coming out of their pocket
to support artists
came out of pocket
more to support charity.
And this isn't the first time
they have done this.
This BTS Army charity gives
a bunch to philanthropic causes.
So, as an artist,
as a performer,
hell, man, we have fun.
You know,
we're doing good stuff.
But if we can resonate
through the television
to you at home
to come out of your pocket
to give to a cause,
like, that's work.
Man, that's work and that's
purpose and that's, like --
That's [bleep]
changing the world.
You know, like,
that's impressive.
That is impressive.
And I don't care how you
feel about them.
I don't care if it's your bag
or it's not.
I get it. It's music.
You have your opinion to like
what you want.
How they conduct themselves
as human beings
and the message
they send to the world --
man, that's something special.
-I want to talk to you
about everything,
because you have "Fast 9."
You have "Suicide Squad 2."
You have
"Elbow Grease: Fast Friends."
-"Elbow Grease: Fast Friends."
-We have --
-It's moving so fast.
-I know!
I want this to go on for
more and more.
Guys, more with John Cena.
You can't leave.
We'll have more with John Cena
when we come back.
You have to stay.
-I'm gonna stay here, though.
6 feet.
-Oh, you're 6 feet.